what is the greatest meal you've ever
had so your last meal let's go
if one more meal i get to
uh murder you after this
this is your last day we get to spend
planet together where in the world would
you go what would you eat
i would say the most delicious thing is
bone marrow and i would love a full meal
of bone marrow for my last last dish i
did on my birthday in 2002
ate a kilogram and a half of crab meat
in kamchatka and that was also amazingly
delicious
uh the king crab they have there is
incredible
but
i would go with bone marrow which is
i think just one of the most delicious
foods and it's sort of this weird body
part you know it's basically all your
stem cells not all of them but the stem
cells that produce all your blood cells
so they are spitting out billions of
white blood cells red blood cells and
platelets every day and there's a bunch
of fat in there as well
just one of the places the body stores
fat and so you basically add heat and
that's all you need it's like the
perfect food you add heat the fat for
frying the stem cells is already there
there's a naturally a bone vessel to
contain it all probably adds some flavor
too it's like the perfect food what does
it matter which which uh which animal
i prefer a larger animal just so there's
more of it i actually like well that's
true i actually really like sort of bone
marrow from like chicken bones right
just sucking it out of the bone yes i'm
i'm known for leaving absolutely nothing
edible on the plate except bone itself
there's one other human i know that
loves
um
bone marrow as much as you do and that's
joe rogan
so go
unnatural how much that man loves bone
marrow i understand why i love the steak
part the bone marrow like you know what
let me um let me argue with you because
i don't know um
it could be an acquired taste but
there's just too much it's like too much
with too little work for it
like it's as if
you gave me lobster meat without the
lobster having to clean the lobster
and i just feel like i'm spoiling myself
there's so it's very fatty it's
i don't know maybe i want to work for
something that tastes like that well if
you start from the whole animal you do
have to work to get at it right a lot of
animals have the um teeth and the jaw
muscles to chomp through bone we do not
so um you know when you buy it from the
store it's already sawed up
but i've definitely gotten marrow out of
deer bones you know with a hatchet just
chop off just chop off the fat end and
start spooning it out or maybe i'll
revisit it that's fascinating and where
where would you eat it
where in which place of the world
is is there something about
who cooks it who you eat it with
um
you're not allowed to pick your family
right uh
so like which place in the world rural
or in the city
those kinds of things you've been to so
many fascinating places
i would say i'm antarctica i would say
is one of the most picturesque places
i've ever been i really did not interest
i didn't know how mountainous it was and
i guess i knew there'd be the ice but
just i didn't know how much ice it was
you know it's ice and mountains just
overwhelming i just you know as as kind
of overwhelming bone marrow might seem
to you sort of that feast for your eyes
um
and just ice in general is amazing like
the icebergs floating around antarctica
is just astounding like the different
shapes the sizes
are uh incredible there's actually a i
believe it's u.s navy website that
tracks the largest icebergs and you can
read about each of them and how big they
are and just
the formations you see similar up near
greenland though i have not been to
greenland um just ice in general is just
amazing so i could just look at its
different forms while eating bone marrow
forever until you kill me that is yeah
and afterwards we go it's back to the
death of the death and sex i
what is it about the ice is it uh sort
of the enormity of nature it just
reminds you that it's going to be there
before you and after
and then you get to partake in the
eating of the um
the thing you need for maintaining of
your biological
temporary biological organism
yeah i think it's a few things one is
just the shapes that you see you know
the wave action
just eating away at these pieces of ice
you get these arches and just these
shapes i mean it's just like geometry
the geometry alone is amazing i studied
math as an undergrad and i've always
appreciated uh geometry
um and just the shapes alone are just
look like brilliant works of modernist
art and just
obviously no two are ever the same
not to mention a lot of them are this
unearthly blue color that is just um
really startling and fascinating the
same color of glaciers
um you know in various parts of the
world that blue color is just really
amazing
and i also just love how it's sort of
this constant shedding
from our antarctic continent from
greenland you know it's this constant
process of snow falling inland and
pushing the glaciers further out to sea
and them breaking loose i mean obviously
it seems to be happening faster these
days but it's sort of this constant
shedding and sort of i always like
thinking about how the body has
something similar you know we're
constantly shedding and renewing and
rebuilding
everything
and so ice is sort of this constant
similar process
you